[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive well in the
next half an hour we'll see what is
making the headlines that's with katie
balls deputy political editor at the
spectator and ian dunt columnist at the
eye newspaper
so let's have a look what is on some of
those front pages well the prime
minister has deployed troops gunships
and missile systems to estonia and
poland to send a clear message to the
russian president vladimir putin that
any threats over ukraine will not be
tolerated that is on the front of the
express
and the government has been accused of
trying to exploit an announcement over
extra funding for poorer areas in
england in a bid to save boris johnson's
job that is according to the observer
and the telegraph reports that there are
calls for an overhaul of the culture at
number 10 and reveals the prime
minister's most senior aide enjoyed
hospitality at lord's cricket ground a
few days before the taliban took control
of afghanistan
now the planned 12 billion pound hike in
national insurance will go ahead that's
according to the sunday times despite
tory backbenchers demanding it be
scrapped and the sunday mail reports on
the harsh reality of the cost of the
living of the cost of living crisis the
paper speaks to a mother who says that
she is being pushed
into poverty
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you can see on your screen
right now you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
also watch us
well we're joined as i was saying
tonight by katie balls deputy political
editor at the spectator and ian dunt
columnist at the eye newspaper really
good to see both of you tonight thank
you for spending saturday evening with
us here on sky news we want to start by
talking uh about the front page of the
sunday express katie pm's defiant
message to hostile putin
yes and this is the announcement uh
overnight that um britain is planning to
actually double the number of troops in
estonia uh right already has as you know
tensions escalate over the situation
with ukraine and russia
and now there's been talk for months
particularly though in recent weeks uh
that russia could be imminent really in
planning to enter ukraine um you have
joe biden the american president said
telling the ukrainian and president to
expect an attack in the next few weeks
and i think this is the
clear sign from many of the western
allies and nato to say
um really think about this to putin and
to suggest that if uh they do proceed if
russia does do this there will be
consequences
yeah ian it's also featuring on the
front of the sunday telegraph as well
with it with an image there of the prime
minister uh being briefed uh by admiral
sir tony radekin the chief of the
defense staff there
yeah but i mean
there is no possible consequence that
would follow from this that would in any
way alarm putin or even make him think
twice or even hesitate the amount of
troops and battalions that putin has
amassed on the ukrainian border means
that he essentially has the military
capacity to do whatever he wants
he can occupy he can install public
governments he can take the west as well
as the east there is really no
limitation on what you can do we're not
sending another 900 troops to estonia
which of course is not the same as
ukraine we do absolutely nothing to make
him think twice about this course of
action i think really when you look at
it and incidentally also when you
remember the things that the british
government is not doing about putin's
aggression for instance the economic
crimes bill that has sat moribund which
would make it much harder for russian
oligarch money to find its way into
london when you look at it as a whole
you think well this is at best
ineffectual and at worst an attempt to
distract from his domestic concerns yeah
that's what i was going to ask you about
katie i mean all the while we've got a
front page devoted entirely
to this deployment of troops there and
and the pm getting involved in this
escalating tension between russia and
ukraine you're not getting front pages
devoted to the probe into parties
yeah and i think on that i think this is
probably a bit more nuanced than you
know either you know the prime
minister's just doing this to not have
to talk about parties and vice versa is
completely you know benevolent of the
prime minister to be interested in this
issue and have no um self-serving calls
to him i think clearly boris johnson's
teamed rally pitches out um not to do
the partygate but of the prime minister
acting tough and talking to his advisors
on this issue
and i think that there would be people
who are talking about ukraine but it's
also a very serious situation and
i agree into a degree in the sense there
are obviously very limited things that
the uh can do if it's not really
planning to enter efforts in war but
we're talking about some sanctions which
could be effective but also i think
sending a signal that nato is not going
to listen to putin's initial demand
which was that you had a decreased nato
uh presence in this area if anything
going uh against that between troops
there um so i think there's a bit of
both going on but i think the situation
in ukraine and russia is happening even
if there is still an ongoing robot about
parties which is damaging to the prime
minister but also isn't the only story
in town yeah what do you think ian um i
mean nobody denies the seriousness of
what is happening uh on the ukraine
border there but is is this really a
monumental dead cat strategy
we've seen the tactic over the last
week two weeks really in fact you can
see boris johnson deploy it in the last
pmqs of just to point out or any other
area of policy to get away from the main
conversation which he does not want to
have indirectly served kiss why won't
you ask me about ukraine jacob reese
moore one of his chief defenders at the
moment leader of the house of commons
was retweeting daily mail headlines
saying haven't we lost proportion
talking about parties rather than
ukraine so i don't think we're being
conspiratorial to suggest that they are
desperate to talk about anything else
they made it very clear that is their
absolute strategy to pursue
the thing is ukraine is deadly serious i
mean what is happening there is an
absolutely abysmal affront to democratic
values coming from a dictator and a
tyrant trying to occupy an autonomous
democratic state now that is a terrible
state of affairs to be in and yet the
problem lies with us of course because
we have gotten ourselves into a
situation where there is a prime
minister so absurd that they would be in
a scandal over parties during lockdown
rather than a position where they could
legitimately and genuinely be paying
attention to what is going on in ukraine
yeah it's easy to to take your eye off
the ball with the very many important
things that are happening not just here
but also in countries like afghanistan
and so on as well um let's move on katie
front page
of the sunday times of course there's
been a lot of
internal row hasn't there about this
proposed rise
in national insurance but it sounds like
they've circled the wagons and prime
minister and chancellor
are both saying now that they are
committed to pushing ahead with that 12
billion pound hike in national insurance
yes and i think the reason that uh it is
now a story that the prime minister and
the chancellor uh
ultimately publicly saying that they
still agree with government policy does
relate to partygate um we've had a
situation where the prime minister's
have been a very perilous position the
past few weeks pressure from his party
over what he knew over the su grave
report which we still don't have out and
questions about her confidence vote and
one of the things that boris johnson and
his supporters have been doing and to
try and sure up his position is to talk
to mps about what needs to change other
than the man himself as far as they see
it um in order to
keep their support and what they kept
hearing from mps is to axe this national
insurance rise and they do not want to
tax rise um the chancellor has been
pushing against this and suggesting it
would be
really uh irresponsible to ultimately
act a tax rise if you don't know what
you're going to replace with given
inflation and it looks as though boris
johnson a combination of listening to
his chancellor so power there and two
thinking he's safe enough to to just
keep going on the current path is going
to stick with it for the time being what
do you think ian this is telling us
about the the internal dynamics of the
conservative party and indeed that the
power base of the prime minister
well it's certainly a victory for sunak
i mean you would have thought that boris
johnson would be absolutely desperate to
go ahead with this as he isn't anything
else because he's entirely desperate to
save his own skin so that believed in
this he seems to have held him to the
fire there's a really interesting little
detail in the article where it suggests
that well he said to the prime minister
look there's no way i'm going to be able
to cut
income tax before the next election
unless we have this go through
especially when you're sort of looking
deeper into the article it reads more
and more like it's soonac that's calling
the shots on this matter at least and
the fact that they got into position
where they could both put their names to
this document would indicate that he is
um using the advantages which he
currently enjoys
it and also katie it points to
a
pretty big philosophical problem that
the conservative party needs to deal
with doesn't it because on one hand you
need to have sound
finances um and on the other hand you're
the party that that doesn't raise taxes
but something's gonna have to give
yes and the fact that boris johnson at
his moment of weakness um after all
these party stories has had the most
regular demand be that he needs to axe
the tax rise points to the level of
unhappiness
the fact that lots of tories think well
this just isn't a tory policy i think
it's going to be really damaging in the
long term and in this article uh signed
by the prime minister the chancellor
they accept they are thatcherites um
which some of their party would uh be
skeptical at that moment but they say
that's about signed sound finances and
therefore i think that particularly for
rishi sunak i think that he
he is struggling to convince his uh
fellow colleagues right now that he is a
low-tech story and that's where there's
such an effort to get to a place where
you can cut taxes ahead of the next
election
also for the tories electoral and
prospects given in certain polling
labors now seem to be more the party of
low taxes which is a strange place to be
i was going to move us on um ian to the
uh front back to the front page of the
sunday telegraph but there's another
article on the front of the sunday times
there talking about the frat house
culture within number 10
led to the the pm himself being banned
from taking uh very highly confidential
documents home because uh the article
says that friends of of his wife were
around and he had them lying around
yeah it reminds you of stories that we
saw a couple of weeks ago of people
having to erect barriers
so that when you know boris johnson had
coveted he was unable to go sort of hang
out with other people and again just
paints this picture of someone who
doesn't have any of the seriousness
or
the maturity of thought in order to
deliver the position of prime minister
and absolutely i mean when you when you
see this is double sourced when you see
this kind of behavior taking place it's
just top secret documents left open on
briefcases with friends of his now wife
being given code so they can enter into
that flat whenever they like you think
in exactly the same way as you do when
you look at the stories of the parties
that this is someone who just doesn't
have the seriousness to be occupying
that position this just seems to be one
further piece of evidence for what is a
pretty unavoidable proposition all right
well plenty more for us to get stuck
into after
the break thank you both for very much
we'll be coming back to you again in a
few moments uh when we come back after
the break the cost of living crisis
leaves families on the brink of poverty
we'll be discussing that
as it features in the papers
[Music]
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me uh now are katie balls deputy
political editor at the spectator and
ian dunt columnist at the eye newspaper
um
we were talking weren't we before the
break about the uh about the national
insurance hike uh which the sunday times
says that the pm and chancellor are
agreed on it that it will be going ahead
and of course the backdrop to all of
this ian is a looming it's already
biting isn't it cost of living crisis
yeah exactly so inflation across the
board
um particularly in energy prices and
once again you see a similar situation
really is when it comes to foreign
policy which is a government that has
done absolutely nothing to help and in
several ways has actually conspired to
make things considerably worse the tax
rise is obviously a case in point but
you see the same if you look at the way
that businesses are treated i mean we
brought in import controls against the
europeans from the first of january what
that means for lots of companies is they
have to start suddenly providing the
customs checks the country of origin
declarations the sanitary and phyto
sanitary declarations all of that costs
a lot of money for companies the people
that get that price passed on to them
are the consumers exactly the same thing
has happened with labor with rising
labor costs as a result of shortages
itself a mixture of covid and brexit
so here again when we start to see the
business end of what this entails i mean
you're seeing the joseph rowntree
foundation warning of 2 000 children in
scotland who are at risk of of hunger
over the winter it's 20 000 it's it's a
bigger part it's a lot worse than that
and
this is the business end of what we're
seeing and once again we see a
government that primarily deals in
inaction and indifference and when it
does do something tends to make the
situation worse
yeah it's on the front page of the
sunday mail also featuring katie on the
front page of the observer and a lot of
commentators saying that this is a
government that
time and time again shows that it
doesn't understand how ordinary people
live
i think you can see that theme in terms
of uh the idea of one real for them and
covered rules and but then as you say in
a way i think the bigger problem for
this government and boris johnson if he
stays in this position is cost of living
and we expect it to get much worse
before it gets any better
and
in terms of the tools the government has
its disposal
it's not clear what they want to use
we're hearing more about what they don't
plan to do than what they do plan to do
so things like you know cutting v80
energy bills lots of these things being
mooted but we're not there again in
terms of any decisions
and it's an interesting story on the
front of the observer which is talking
about you know these um buy now pay
later and companies i think clan is one
of the most famous and tends to be more
focused on you know electricity products
all these and now you're seeing some of
these other companies targeting those
who are clearly vulnerable saying
you can use us to do your weekly shop so
if we're getting to the point where
rising prices means uh that all of a
sudden even the weekly shop is looking
very difficult to do i think rishi sunic
and boris johnson are going to come
under more pressure to come up something
sooner rather than later and one's
mutual you know this idea of one of
payments to the most in need but again
working out how to reach those people so
it's very complicated and i think hard
for the government to um
really um effectively do um at the
moment yeah all right both thank you
very much